hey everyone it's me danny seo you just
saw me and drew
make a beautiful sticky toffee oatmeal
dessert and one of the hero ingredients
was flaxseed and i want to show you what
to do with the leftover flaxseed
you can make a homemade non-toxic slime
using flax seeds and a few simple
ingredients for the flax seeds
i am soaking about a cup of flax seeds
and two cups of warm water overnight and
what happens is
is that it gets really gelatinous sticky
and
kind of perfect for a sticky slime right
in here
you're gonna dump that whole thing into
a bowl the next thing that you need is
about a teaspoon
to two teaspoons of something called
xanthan gum and xanthan gum you probably
don't have
in your pantry but this is what it looks
like when you go to the store
it's in this little bag a lot of
confectionery um
pastry stuff to use xanthan gum as a
binder and you're going to put this
into the bowl two teaspoons of this
and don't worry if it doesn't mix in
because it's not going to blend in
perfectly it's going to kind of separate
actually
but you do want to whisk it so that the
xanthan gum is
kind of like mixed in well enough at
this point you want to add your natural
food dye and so i'm going to use a
little bit of blue
food dye for our slime just a few little
squirts
so if you're doing a liquid food dye
like four drops will do this is a gel so
i have like
a little bit of a squirt of that you can
see right away
that it's turning this beautiful blue
color right now and then there's one
more step
you want to take cornstarch so we're
going to take an entire 16
ounce container of cornstarch and
we're just going to incorporate this a
little bit at a time and what you're
going to find
is that it starts to bind together and
turn into
a really incredible slime you can see
already
in just a few seconds
i'm getting a really sticky ooey
gooey slime